♪
>> Sean: EVEN DEMOCRATS TONIGHT,
THEY'RE STARTING TO COME CLEAN
ABOUT JOE BIDEN'S OBVIOUS
COGNITIVE STRUGGLES.
JUST TAKE A LOOK AT THIS ARTICLE
FROM THE AP ABOUT CONGRESSMAN
MONDARE JONES AND THE INTERACT
HE HAD WITH PRESIDENT SIPPY CUP.
HE TOLD PRESIDENT JOE BIDEN HIS
PARTY NEEDED HIM MORE INVOLVED
IN PASSING VOTING LEGISLATION ON
THE HILL.
IN RESPONSE HE SAID, BIDEN JUST
SORT OF STARED AT ME JONES SAID
DESCRIBING AN AWKWARD SILENCE
THAT PASSED BETWEEN THE TWO.
NOW THE AP DESCRIBED THIS AS,
QUOTE, A LACKLUSTER ENGAGEMENT.
LET ME TRANSLATE THAT.
JOE BIDEN IS CHECKED OUT.
HE'S COGNITIVELY WEAK.
HE'S WEAK PHYSICALLY.
HE'S WEAK MENTALLY.
HE'S A COGNITIVE MESS.
EVEN HIS OWN PARTY IS STARTING
TO ADMIT THE OBVIOUS.
STILL DON'T BELIEVE ME?
JUST WATCH SIPPY CUP AT HIS
REMARKS EARLIER TODAY ON GUN
CONTROL.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> THE BLOOD OF PATRIOTS, YOU
KNOW, AND ALL THE STUFF ABOUT
HOW WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO MOVE
AGAINST THE GOVERNMENT.
WELL, THE TREE OF LIBERTY IS NOT
WATER ON THE BLOOD OF PATRIOTS.
WHAT'S HAPPENED IS THAT THERE
HAVE NEVER BEEN -- IF YOU WANTED
TO THINK YOU NEED TO HAVE
WEAPONS TO TAKE ON THE
GOVERNMENT, YOU NEED F-15s AND
MAYBE SOME NUCLEAR WEAPONS.
POLICE CHIEF MURRAY OF THE
BALTIMORE -- EXCUSE ME, POLICE
CHIEF MERRICK.
POLICE CHIEF MURPHY, PAUL, OF
BATON ROUGE, LOUISIANA,
CONFIRMING MY OUTSTANDING
NOMINEE TO LEAD THE AFT.
EXCUSE ME, THE ATF.
DAVID CHIPMAN.
THEY'LL TELL YOU THERE'S NO
POSSIBLE JUSTIFICATION FOR
HAVING A HUNDRED ROUNDS IN A
MAGAZINE OF A GUN.
LIKE I SAID BEFORE, WHAT DO YOU
THINK?
THE DEER WEARING KEPLAR INVESTS?
>> Sean: THAT SEEM LIKE SOMEONE
WITH THE ALERTNESS MENTAL
CAPACITY TO BE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES UNITED STATES?
THAT'S THE HARDEST JOB IN THE
WORLD.
I HAVE TO BE HONEST, A LOT ISN'T
EVEN FUNNY ANYMORE PRETTY
SERIOUS.
HERE'S REACTION WITH LOUISIANA
SENATOR JOHN KENNEDY.
SENATOR FOR ME THIS IS NOT A
MATTER OF JOE'S AGE.
I'LL GIVE YOU AN EXAMPLE.
BERNIE SANDERS.
BERNIE SANDERS IS AS SHARP AS HE
WAS 20 YEARS AGO PUSHING HIS
RADICAL SOCIALISM, COME
ANYTHINGS WHATEVER HE WAS
PUSHING AT THE TIME.
HE HAS ENERGY, HE'S ALERT, HE'S
ARTICULATE AND HAS PASSION IN
WHAT HE DOES.
YOU SEE THE PRESIDENT EVERY DAY.
I'M PLAYING THESE TAPES EVERY
NIGHT.
IT'S AN OBVIOUS PROBLEM.
IT SEEMS DEGENERATIVE.
I WOULD ASSUME THE PRESSURES OF
THE OFFICE MIGHT ACCELERATE
WHATEVER'S GOING ON HERE.
DR. RONNIE JACKSON THINKS HE
NEEDS A COGNITIVE TEST.
WHAT ARE YOUR THOUGHTS?
>> WELL, SEAN, I LISTENED TO THE
PRESIDENT'S PRESS CONFERENCE
TODAY, AND THERE WERE TIMES WHEN
I WAS CONFUSED.
LET ME SPEAK TO THE SUBSTANCE,
THOUGH.
I DON'T HATE ANYONE, BUT WHOEVER
IS ADVISING THE PRESIDENT ON
CRIME, AND I DON'T KNOW WHO IT
IS, BUT WHOEVER IT IS, IS -- HIS
SECRET SERVICE NAME OUGHT TO BE
BUTT-HEAD.
I MEAN, WHY HAS CHICAGO BECOME
THE WORLD'S LARGEST OUTDOOR
SHOOTING RANGE?
WHY IS IT SAFER TO WALK DOWN THE
STORES OF IN, ON GIDISHU THAN
NEW YORK CITY.
CRIME IS NOT UP, AS THE
PRESIDENT SEEMED TO INDICATE
TODAY, BECAUSE OF INADEQUATE
BACKGROUND CHECKS.
CRIME IS UP BECAUSE MANY, NOT
ALL, BUT MANIES MEMBERS OF THE
PRESIDENT'S OWN PARTY BELIEVE IN
DEFUNDING THE POLICE.
THEY RAN ON IT.
AND IN MANY CITIES THEY'VE DONE
IT.
CRIME IS UP BECAUSE MANY MEMBERS
OF THE PRESIDENT'S OWN PARTY
WANT TO TURN COPS INTO SOCIAL
WORKERS.
CRIME IS UP BECAUSE MANY MEMBERS
OF THE PRESIDENT'S OWN PARTY
THINK ALL COPS ARE RACIST,
INCLUDING, APPARENTLY, THE
AFRICAN AMERICAN POLICE
OFFICERS.
CRIME IS UP BECAUSE MANY MEMBERS
OF THE PRESIDENT'S OWN PARTY
THINK THAT WHEN A COP SHOOTS A
CRIMINAL, IT'S ALWAYS THE COP'S
FAULT.
BUT WHEN A CRIMINAL SHOOTS A
COP, IT'S ALWAYS THE GUN'S
FAULT.
NOW, MOST PEOPLE IN AMERICA KNOW
THAT.
AND WE'RE NOT GOING TO GET IN
CONTROL OF THIS CRIME SITUATION
UNTIL WE DO THREE THINGS.
UNTIL PRESIDENT BIDEN DOES THREE
THINGS.
NUMBER ONE, FUND THE POLICE.
GIVE THEM THEIR MONEY BACK.
NUMBER TWO, LET COPS BE COPS.
LET THEM DO THEIR JOB.
NOW, IF THEY MISBEHAVIOR, IF
THEY DON'T FOLLOW THE LAW,
PUNISH THEM.
HOLD THEM ACCOUNTABLE, LIKE WE
DID WITH DEREK CHAUVIN BUT MOST
COPS FOLLOW THE LAW.
AND NUMBER THREE, WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE TO DO WHAT MAYOR GIULIANI
AND MAYOR BLOOMBERG DID IT IN
NEW YORK CITY AND WE HAVE TO DO
IT IN ALL THE MAJOR CRIME
ERRORS, WE HAVE TO BRING BACK
STOP, QUESTION AND FRISK AND
APPLY IT IN A RACIALLY NEUTRAL
MANNER.
IT IS PERFECTLY LEGAL.
IT HAS BEEN USED FOR YEARS.
CHIEF JUSTICE EARL WARREN WROTE
THE OPINION IN 1968, A CASE
CALLED TERRY V OHIO THAT SAYS IT
IS PERFECTLY LEGAL TO STOP,
QUESTION AND FRISK IF YOU DO IT
IN A RACIALLY NEUTRAL MANNER.
AND UNTIL WE DO -- I MEAN, THIS
BUSINESS OF THE CONFUSION FROM
THE PRESS CONFERENCE, AND THIS
BUSINESS OF BACKGROUND CHECKS
AND -- I MEAN, IT'S JUST
DRIBBLE.
AND I THINK MOST AMERICANS KNOW
IT.
>> Sean: LET ME ASK, AS YOU SEE
CRIME IN ALL OF THESE CITIES,
AND YOU SEE, FOR EXAMPLE, WE
JUST HAD NEW YORK, AN
ANNOUNCEMENT THAT ALL THE PEOPLE
THAT WERE INVOLVED IN ARSON, ALL
THE PEOPLE INVOLVED IN LOOTING,
PEOPLE WE HAVE VIDEOTAPES OF
THEM DOING, COMMITTING THESE
CRIMES, NONE OF THEM ARE GOING
TO BE PROSECUTED.
YOU HAVE DEFUNDING THE POLICE,
YOU HAVE DISMANTLING THE POLICE
AND NO BAIL LAWS TAKING OVER IN
THE COUNTRY.
I DON'T KNOW, SENATOR, I'M JUST
A SIMPLE GUY, I'M JUST A LITTLE
TALK SHOW HOST.
I JUST DON'T SEE ANY OF THAT
ENDING WELL.
I LIKE TO ASK PEOPLE THE
QUESTION, IF WE DISMANTLED,
DEFUND THE POLICE, WHAT ARE YOU
GOING TO DO IF, GOD FORBID
SOMEBODY BREAKS INTO YOUR HOME
LATE AT NIGHT?
SENATOR, I'M PRETTY SURE YOU
HAVE A PLAN.
I KNOW I HAVE MY PLAN.
I'M NOT GOING TO BE COUNTING ON
OTHER PEOPLE TO PROTECT ME IN MY
LIFE.
BUT MOST PEOPLE DON'T HAVE A
PLAN AND MANY PEOPLE AREN'T
CAPABLE OF EVEN FOLLOWING UP ON
A PLAN IF THEY DID HAVE ONE.
>> WELL, HOW CAN I PUT THIS?
YOU REMEMBER, YOU REMEMBER HOW
YOU FELT -- YOU REMEMBER HOW
PEOPLE PANICKED WHEN THEY
COULDN'T FIND TOILET PAPER?
IMAGINE HOW THEY'RE GOING TO
FEEL WHEN THEY CAN'T FIND A COP?
AND THAT'S WHERE WE'RE HEADED
HERE.
THIS ATTITUDE AMONG MANY, NOT
ALL, BUT MANY OF MY DEMOCRATIC
COLLEAGUES THAT WE CAN, WE CAN
HAVE ORDER WITHOUT JUSTICE, THAT
WE CAN HAVE ORDER WITHOUT LAW
ENFORCEMENT, IS, IS NONSENSE.
I DON'T KNOW WHERE IT CAME FROM.
UNFORTUNATELY, I DON'T KNOW WHY,
BUT THERE ARE PEOPLE IN THIS
WORLD, THEY'RE NOT MIXED UP,
THEY'RE NOT CONFUSED, THEY'RE
NOT SICK.
IT'S NOT A QUESTION OF WHETHER
THEIR MOMMY OR DADDY LOVED THEM
ENOUGH.
THEY'RE JUST ANTISOCIAL.
AND SOCIETY HAS TO BE PROTECTED
AND WE HAVE TO HAVE COPS TO DO
IT.
>> Sean: I CAN'T SAY IT ANYMORE
SIMPLY.
YOU'VE DONE A GREAT JOB FOR THE
PEOPLE OF LOUISIANA, SENATOR.
WE'RE SUPPORTING A